اسبوع ثان من الحرب في السودان لا صوت
يعلو على صوت الرصاص والمعارك تكوي ارضه
دون حسم نهائي لاي من الطرفين هدنه خامسه
قد توقف اطلاق النار نسبيا لكنها لن توقف
الحرب جغرافيا وساحه المواجهه الاساسيه
تحركت غربا من الخرطوم الى ولايه دارفور
حيث بدا الجيش السوداني بنقل جزء من
معركته في الخرطوم الى الجنينه عاصمه
ولايه غرب دارفور والسبب قطع الطريق على
قوات الدعم السريع ومنع نقل معدات عسكريه
من الاقليم الى الخرطوم اما ابعادها
تستهدف قطع شرايين الجغرافيا وتفريغ جيوب
الاقليم من اي قوه مسلحه تشكل دعما لحمته
لاندلاع الاشتباكات في الجنينه عده دلالات
فالبرهان يريد تخفيف الضغط العسكري في
العاصمه الخرطوم اضافه الى تشتيت انتباه
قوات الدعم السريع لكن ما يخش الجيش
السوداني في دارفور هو تاثيرات البيئه
الاجتماعيه والجغرافيه المتشابكه حيث تنشط
قوات الدعم السريع بحكم الامتدادات
القبليه التي تصل تشاد وربما تنحاز لصالح
متي في لحظه معينه من المعارك مراقبون
حذروا من ان حياد الحركات المسلحه في
دارفور قد لا يستمر طويلا اذا اشتد القتال
في الاقليم ويمكن ان تنحاز الى الجيش او
الدعم السريع اما الرعب الاكبر عند
السودانيين يكمن في حصر القتال في دارفور
مجددا فاذا تفوق الجيش على قوات الدعم
السريع في الخرطوم لن يكون امام الاخيره
سوى التحسن في دارفور فتح جبهه دارفور
مجددا يعيد الى الاذهان اجواء الحرب
الاهليه السابقه خصوصا ان من صنعوا
انتصارات الامس اصبحوا اعداء اليوم اياد
حمود العربيه
متابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات